j'ai couru, j'en ai marre d'endurer, je suis fatigué
Je suis fatigué de me taire, je suis fatigué d'avoir peur et tu es fatigué
tolérer
[applaudissements]
Toi
[musique]
caoutchouc
les gens veulent vraiment du changement
Combien de temps pouvez-vous contrôler votre peuple ?
tu sais, contre leur volonté, nous avons même
le président du pouvoir et comment j'ai parlé à
la télévision parce que les gens la veulent
mais parce qu'il ne veut pas d'elle
pouvoir donné
[musique]
j'espère qu'après tout tu changeras, eh bien
nous effectuerons d'abord honnêtement
élections, nous changerons la constitution qui
Je crois qu'il ne devrait pas y avoir de dirigeants
Eh bien, c'est-à-dire que le président a plus de deux mandats
[musique]
soutenir les changements dans le pays et beaucoup
Je veux que ces élections soient équitables et
Quelque chose a changé dans notre pays pour le mieux
quelque chose s'est passé et les gens
commencé à s'organiser quand
ils ont mis Sergei comme un véritable leader
une grande masse de gens semble n'avoir aucun chef
tout le monde devrait s'enfuir
mais les gens l'ont montré pour constater que ça se sentait
ils sont venus à l'organisation pour ces
piquets de grève pour recueillir des signatures
[musique]
J'ai tout fait pour protéger
les enfants vont plus loin parce que bon, je ne sais pas
parce que Sergei était très courageux
Je n'ai jamais pensé que j'étais comme ça
parce que la vie devant moi n'a jamais
définir de telles tâches, je ne savais tout simplement pas
que tu as un tel courage en moi cependant
En fait, j'ai peur parce qu'il est si courageux
Humain
[musique]